có nghĩ thứ chủ tính nước to lâm, cùng các đồ chỉ lãnh đạo đàng, nha nước lãnh đạo thành phố, đã tới dân hà từng lã chủ tịch của chính lưng.
Trò năm 2019, nếu hai thêm bệnh là một hình chính trăm bệ sấu,
của họ khoảng sau đã quyết nịnh chính thức là tên thành phố xài gòn ra định là thành phố hồ chính mình.
Quên định này không chỉ là một sự kiện hành chính, mà là kết tinh tình cảm thiên liên là một lòng biên ơn sồ nạn của những dân ta đối với chủ tịch của chính mình kính yêu.
Là sự viện nhận chuyển thống cách mạng kinh cường, có khóc và những nòng có tò lưỐn của sài gòn ra định trong lối chính giải phống dân ta cũng thống nhất đất nước,
người gặp nghiệm tiên kỳ vọng và chính nghiệp đối với một thường phố có việc chỉ đặc biệt của cả nước.
Tổng nghĩ thứ chủ tính nước tổng lòng hàng định, lấy khi niệm là gì để tăng đàng tất dân tổng tận của ta,
thành kính tưởng như không lao trở biển của báo hồ vì đại.
Chien các thế hệ kinh mạng tiên mối, những người đã công dính hiến khi xin vì đột lập tự gió của tổ quốc,
vì sự nghiệp dài phống miền nằm thống nhất đất nước, vì sự chựa thành và phát triển của thành phố mạng trên đác.
Nói đến thành phố chim mình là nói đến một phung đất rộng trên thống yêu nước, tích mạng.
Những tầy nhìn và sáng đạng, một phung đất luôn đẹp lên như giá trị trong đẹp sức tọng.
Đúng thầy không được mạng đường, trị thăm mọng bơi.
Chính trường thành phố này, tự vấn nhận dòng, tất đầy một trong mấy đam lòng, người tình như điều đất mỗi tất cả những đáu trạng thịt bờ đúng.
Mà đau thành trình lịch sử tìm đát ngần lại phong trên đặc lại phong đất nước.
Bốt khi nhất đến thành phố chim mình đến đến nhà đồng trong tục tức vấn người,
về đam lại vang mọng tâm gần thăm vọng kí thương liên, về từ thành phố này người đạng.
Rồi đi, về điểm kời đau của một thành trình gì đại từ lần người,
ở ý, giúp tập đá tìm thấy có đường được lập tự gió mạng hấn sấu tục tị sao,
cũng chính thành bối được đại bóng thống nhất trọng vẻ trong lòng thuộc quốc vĩ dựa hào
mang tên trụ tình phố chim mình kính yêu.
Không lạnh, xong năm nay đau, trụ tất cả những giống như rằng tình gọi ấy không chỉ là nêm từ hào của lịch sử,
mà còn là yêu cầu hiện tại mà tức này không chỉ là dân xin cầu vĩ,
mà là trần mất là tình vố tự giói tự giói tự giói tự vấn lệ nổi ngày.
Nếu bật những tăng tiêu của thành phố, tầm bị thơ cho tính nước tối lâm trọng,
như lại năm nay năm không phải để bằng lòng với chiếc quan đạt được mà để bước tiếp mạnh mẹ hơn.
Nhất là sau khi sắp sếp đâm bị hành chính, không ra phát triển của thành phố được mở giọt với quy mô và tình năng lớn hơn.
Thành phố hồ chỉ mình mới hội tụi những lợt thế giác quan trọng của mình rất lúc đau.
Có chỉ thức có trách nhiệm có nghĩa tình, trên tình tình đó,
tụi giữ trụ tính nước tối lâm yêu cầu thường phố,
thực hiện tốt sấu dịch vụ trọng tâm.
Nó là tức tụi xí dự nặng bộ và hẹp tụi chính khí trong sạch bự mạnh,
tâm hiện đạt xanh thông mình đôi mối mạnh mẹ mô in tăng trường
để khoa công nghệ đôi mối sáng tạo trên đôi sấu kinh tế xanh,
kinh tế tình tệ tình tệ giữ liệu làm đậu được trụi lâu.
Trâm lo tốt hầu đời dụi giống nhân dân và sĩ dự tình phố thình chục tập hộ nhiều quốc tế năng độc,
có mạnh sắc có trách nhiệm.
Sĩ khai.
Mặc hồ kinh hiểu, luôn dành tình cảm tắc bệt sâu làm trường bão.
Mẹn làm trột tị người trường loại, mẹn làm, luôn lần trong trái tị tối.
Tình cảm, tức lấy gọi là niềm bình dự lần loại,
bởi vì là nha đặc nha giọng sâu sắc tốt tành phố mạnh mời.
Bởi con người gọi niềm, mẹn mẹn hộ, nhớ phần hình như tình hộ,
đại xin đăng bệnh giềm tý nhiều sự ký vọng và niềm tình hảo, cảm ước.
Tất cả mấy, không chỉ thuộc về lạnh đạo thành phố, không chỉ thuộc về không chỉ chỉ,
mà còn thuộc về mối người rất thành phố chỉ mình.
Nhưng người đang hàng ngày có phần làm giọng giọng giọng giọng.
Tình đó, tức liên ngon viên mà thành phố bình dự đồng ar.
Tình tự trở đến đối tố làm mối nguồn đặc bộ chính quyền với nhân dân trình phố,
tức thuộc nươi giật xác phọng lớn, hay gặp lớn, trách nhiệt lớn,
mỗi cắn phố về tự hoài, vực mình làm hôm nay đã xin đăng với thường phố mặc thêm bắt chứa.
Bối cơ quan về tự hoài, tức phố vộ của mình đã làm cho lần dân giọng giọng giọng giọng giọng.
Mối địch xuống đánh vị về tự hoài đã hai khắc tốt tường năng,
Thao gọi mẹng đêm đẹn sử dụng quả vốn lúc khách triệu ở tổng bị thư dụng tổ là phía dụng
Năm 5 năm qua thử của đại viết mê chẳng sử v vang sử dụng dở trên vang
Và năm 5 năm tới, phải đyết tiếp một chương phát triển mối, lớn hơn, đẹp hơn, xuống đáng hơn, dịch dụng dở hơn
Chờ thành lỗi thịt văn bình dịch đã nghĩa tình
Nơi tình hỏi hồi chi Minh ngẹn gà sáng, không trình yêu, văn hóa con người, khách vọc bà trình hiện với tụi quốc